foreign
[Music]
good morning
and welcome
today's session we will spend time
together talking about how sap
Enterprises are accelerating data
Innovation with the cortex framework
to introduce you to today my name is
Allison Hedrick I'm director of
solutions of Cortex framework I have
along with me today
hi I'm Lucia subari and I'm the
technical lead for cortex framework and
and I'm Philip I'm director of data at
Google
we have a number of things that we plan
to cover in today's session
first we want to cover what's top of
mind for many Enterprises and our
clients
number two we'll give you an overview of
the cortex framework
number three we'll talk about how group
of ochocario is innovating with the
cortex framework and some of the unique
things that they are doing as part of
their Journey with us
will help you understand where to learn
more as well as take a portion of
today's session for those of you who are
bold you see the mic in the center aisle
will be taking questions
so with that let's get started what's
top of mind for Enterprises today are
really around three main areas
number one is how to break down the data
silos between different applications
within the Enterprise and between and
across data
the second area is around how to improve
insights with data and last but not
least and most importantly for many
Enterprises it's about looking at how to
innovate and do so faster
so how are we helping our clients
accelerate their Journey with data and
AI
and what does that mean
about two years ago we introduced the
cortex framework into the market
and the cortex framework really focuses
on three main things the first is
a set of reference architectures that
can help to simplify delivery of data
and analytics use cases and innovation
the second element is a set of
deployment accelerators so this includes
content to help kick-start your journey
and the third area focuses on
package services that are delivered with
our partners that can help you to
streamline and fast track your
deployment
so what's in the cortex framework
well first we're focused on the
availability of strategic data sets
across a variety of different data
sources delivered through one Foundation
the second element of the framework
focuses on how to deliver insights
through packaged examples and solution
comment content for many different use
cases we've looked at the common use
case patterns across a variety of
different scenarios
and we're providing accelerator and
package content for different types of
use cases
the last area is that our framework the
content we're developing the reference
architecture examples are based on our
open data and AI platform
so what's in the cortex framework
it starts with the ability to connect to
a variety of different data sets and
data sources
both Google delivered
Enterprise such as sap for example
as well as public and community
we're flexible with the framework in
meeting you where you are in providing a
stream line in very flexible way to
ingest and manage data utilizing Google
tooling or your tooling of choice
and in the framework itself we're
providing packaged data models in Google
bigquery as well as data processing
scripts and templates
on top of that we make it very easy for
you to share data externally with our
application layer
as well as realize analytics insights
and visualization faster with our
example looker blocks and templates
as well as our machine learning content
that now is starting to incorporate the
latest advancements with large language
models and generative AI
we're delivering all of this for a
combination of different use cases
Chief among them include things like
sales and marketing supply chain
sustainability
and finance
as you take a closer look at one of the
cornerstones of the cortex framework
there are a variety of different data
sets what you see represented here is
just a sampling for purposes of this
discussion
we have a very rich set of data models
that you can start to take advantage of
and the benefit to you is that we're
taking the guesswork out of how to
manage and integrate data for a variety
of these different packaged use cases
and scenarios and what's nice about the
foundation is that you can rapidly
apply the data foundation and content
across a variety of different use cases
Chief among them
data based on your sap Erp based
environments what I'll do now is turn it
over to my colleague Lucia
who will provide you with a deep dive
around what's in the framework and some
of the technical aspects and highlights
so over to you Lucia
thank you Allison let me unlock my
machine because of course
it would do that
and if we turn it over to the demo I
would like to show you how you actually
get started I only have five minutes
though so I'll go as fast as I can but
I'm happy to stick around for the Q a or
outside the room for one-on-one chats
our demo starts with GitHub and that is
one of the great things about the data
Foundation that we're open source one of
the reasons why we're open source is
that we know that each customer will
have their own unique business rules to
apply and that means that you need to be
able to tweak our models and you need to
be able to adapt them to those business
rules to make your business users happy
so we're happy to provide this through
an open source framework
now if you were to get started even if
you're new to Google cloud in general if
you haven't done any gcp or bigquery
related stuff before we got you covered
so if you head over to the GitHub for
which we'll have the link afterwards
you'll see that we have a lot of
documentation including the reference
architectures the
erts for the different data models for
everything that we have including sapcc
S4 Salesforce and the marketing content
that today has campaign manager take
Talk and Google ads and then when you're
ready you're going to click on this I'm
going to show The Full Experience
little button here and this button will
basically clone the repository and start
to set you up for a sample demo
implementation that will include test
data so if you're starting here what I
would recommend is to get a project from
scratch a new one and have all the
permissions that you can for that
project and and be sure that you can
throw it away and when you're ready
you're going to configure this deployer
it's going to ask you what you want to
implement from all of our samples and
it's going to check dependencies it's
going to check that you have the data
sets that you need to get started and
all the GCS buckets and you will have
the chance to choose if you want to
deploy everything or subsets of our
content within our accelerators
the beauty about this is that it will
show you what good looks like in the
sense that after this 25 minute
deployment finishes you will be able to
jump into bigquery and see what the data
does with our models so again this is
going to take 25 minutes so I'm going to
go into bigquery to show what the end
result is what you will find in bigquery
is in my case I chose
all of the data sets so I have a set of
raw Landing data sets and change data
capture data sets and then we have the
reporting layer so I cannot go into the
details of what those other two data
sets are but basically what you need to
understand is that we build this under a
principle of openness which means that
we are prepared for you to use any
integration tool as long as that
replicates the exact same Source
structure so for example in the case of
sap if you were to use any integration
tool as long as you have the tables with
the same names and the same data types
as sap created them we will handle them
in our reporting models I went straight
into the sap reporting here but you have
models for a lot of other things if you
want to play with them we have over a
hundred models today and these models
eventually get consumed by our
looker dashboards now going back to the
principle of openness that I was
mentioning the lucar dashboards include
a lot of out of the box
samples and dashboards to feed for your
business users around finance and order
to Cache supply chain and inventory
management but if you decided to use
another reporting tool we're cool with
that too and you will find all of the
little joints and filtering that we
applied in Locker in Sample view so that
you can take that into a tableau for
example
so Allison was mentioning the
application layer as well and I want to
give that a little shout out the
application layer is a nice way of
getting onboarded into microservices
that can tap into Data in the cortex
framework so if you were to run our
machine learning models that come out of
a box or product recommendation or
customer segmentation you would use for
example the application layer that will
do do everything so that you have either
a microservice exposing an HTTP endpoint
or a pub sub to write back into for
example an sap system using the app SDK
the other thing that you'll find in the
marketplace is demand sensing demand
sensing is one of our samples that
combines large language models and
machine learning to provide forecasting
for sales out of historical order sales
orders and different data signals coming
from Google search Trends and Google ads
and for example the weather
now with that I am in my five minutes
and I'm going to invite Philip to tell
us how they are using groupobotic area
cortex in grouponicario
thank you Lucia
[Applause]
so before I talk a little bit about our
case at Group Chicago how we use cortex
I'd like to give you a brief overview of
what Chicago is and what we do because I
assume most of you have never heard of
us before so
is a Brazilian beauty company so we make
and we sell beauty products for example
products for personal hygiene fragrances
Skin Care shampoo sunscreen makeup and
perfume
is a multi-brand company so we have nine
nine home Brands our most popular brand
is called ubuchicario which has also
been voted for the fifth consecutive
year in a row as the most popular Beauty
brand in Brazil
but we also have licensed Brands
internationally known Brands such as
Australian Gold or bio oil
second we are an omnichannel company so
we have more than 4 000 physical retail
stores
we have a single brand a multi-brand
e-commerce sites we sell through b2c B2B
direct sales and we offer a true
omni-channel experience for our
consumers through in-store pickup a
single loyalty program and a unified
customer View
and last but not least a Grupo chicaro
has a very high degree of integration so
we operate on the whole value chain
this means we start with research and
development then we produce that Pro the
products in one of our three factories
we distribute them and we also sell them
through our various channels so having
said that we don't only consider
ourselves as a beauty retail company but
as an ecosystem because we also offer
digital products and services to other
retailers which go products which go far
beyond just as selling perfume or makeup
I brought you some big numbers to give
an overview of how this translates in
our like day-to-day operations
is now more than 40 years on the market
we have more than 4 000 physical retail
stores
our products are sold in more than 50
countries we have 15 000 direct
employees we make more than 600 million
items per year we launched more than 600
new products each year
and we also have the largest e-commerce
Beauty Marketplace in Latin America and
this makes us also the biggest cosmetic
franchise on the planet so we have own
stores and we also have stores operated
by franchise partners
uh however buchikaru hasn't always been
a digital company right we were founded
in the 70s
and the company made a huge investment
from 2019 onwards so our technology
technology team back then had about 200
people and now about four years later we
are nearly 3 000 people and a big part
of this investment was also made in data
so the team I'm working with
and one of our first tasks was to move
data to the cloud so we started quite
late in comparison to other countries so
we started in 2019 and we choose
bigquery as the core of our data
platform
why did we choose bigquery because we
like the on-demand model and we didn't
want to worry about sizing so we needed
speed that's why we choose bigquery
however our data stack is not just
limited to the bigquery basically
everything is built on top of a mix of
Open Source Products for example for the
data catalog and other gcp products so
we use for example Pub sub we use data
proc data flow looker just to mention a
few and vertex AI so all of our AI
models or ml models the pipelines are
all running on vertex Ai and today we
already have more than 60 applications
so using AI where we embedded AI into
the process or where we used AI to
change the process
I brought here three examples
of how we use AI specifically to our
industry so we use for example AI to
forecast demand to predict demand we
have a very sophisticated model which
does this prediction based on a point of
sale and SKU level so we look how much
each store will sell of each product and
this in turn feeds back into the factory
so we determine how much we want to sell
how much do we need to produce and this
number goes back to the factories and
then we use also AI to distribute this
inventory across all the stores So to
avoid overstocking or stock out
we also use AI to determine the best
locations for new stores so we are
opening quite a lot quite a few stores
each year and since last year all the
locations are determined by a model
which uses more than 2 700 variables to
determine the best location
and the third example I brought you to
share with you is from research and
development we have a product a model
which we call internal internally Lira
and it's used to automate quality tests
as I mentioned before we launched 600
new products each year and we also make
changes to existing products so to the
formulas of existing products and every
time this happens we need to run dozens
of tests to make sure that the product
when we change the formula still behaves
the way it was designed to behave for
example if we use sunscreen as uh when
we change the formula we need to make
sure that the product maintains its
viscosity if it's exposed for example to
a higher temperatures let's say 30
degrees Celsius that's I don't know how
much is a Fahrenheit but imagine hot
summer day we need to make sure that it
still works the same way it was supposed
to work previously we had to make all
these tests in the real world so we took
the sunscreen put it in a box heated
that box
and put it away that we came back two
weeks later to see if it still maintains
characteristics and today we can use AI
to automate like test and make those
tests you know like a virtual
environment
which helps us to reduce time to Mark
and also helps us to create much more
detailed audit reports which are
required by the regulatory organ in
Brazil to get those products approved
so as you can imagine this the data used
by these models hasn't always been
available in Google Cloud lots of this
data sets comes from transactional
systems like sap in our case we are
using ECC and Hana
and we were suffering until 2021 to get
this data ingested into gcp so what was
the issue these tables these tables has
been have been created like more than a
decade ago and back then not necessarily
always what you would consider best
practices they were applied so we had no
time stamp we had to run full ingestions
to get this data into gcp and we're
talking about tables uh huge tables with
up to 100 billion rows so we had to
split these big Tails into several
chunks we need it on the one hand and
sap architect who was able to decipher
that schema for our Cloud Engineers so
we needed always two groups of people on
the one side sap experts on the other
side the cloud or or data engineers and
they had to somehow meet in the middle
to make these injections happen and some
of those it took several weeks up to
month
so which was a very frustrating process
as we always not always but sometimes we
encountered errors along the way this
could be errors related to to coding
just coding errors but also problems
related to resources so that our
connection for example got got cut off
in the middle of ingestion because we
were putting too much load on the
production database
so if you think of a timeline we're
talking here about early 2021 mid-2021
and at the end of the year we we thought
this is not sustainable not scalable we
need to change something because our
data engineering team which was already
quite big then like 150 people they were
spending about 80 percent of the time
just with data ingestion right so
instead of spending time to prepare data
to clean data prepared for analysis for
for AI they were spending their time
just to get that data from sap to gcp
so we tried SLT which helped us in the
sense that we now had CDC but all of the
data filtering and deduplication still
required Engineers so
this is where cortex came into play and
this was a real game changer for us we
implemented cortex at the end of 2021
and all of the heavy lifting so
understanding which data is new which
actually do we need to bring into gcp
all the mapping the filtering and
deduplication is now being done by
Cortex and since more than a year and
for us it was like this was a game
changer because our Engineers were now
able to focus on tasks which create more
value such as instead of spending their
time to ingest data they were able to
move data from from the raw layer to the
trusted and refined layer where we have
more actually use for the data right so
this was a huge gain for us we were able
to cut the time the average time from
the moment someone requested data until
that data was available we have we used
to it used to take us nine days and I'm
not talking about these uh several these
ingestions which took weeks a month but
the average time was nine days we were
able to cut the time to today two hours
as I mentioned before our data Engineers
they can also focus on tasks which
create more value
and we were able to reduce deploy
incidents to zero this was also very
frustrating once you thought okay
everything should be working then after
a couple of days you got an area had to
start all over again and investigate
what was going wrong
and last but not least a cortex is also
a huge accelerator for our ECC to S4
migration so we are migrating right now
and if we had to do it the old way you
could easily add like one year at least
on top of the time necessary to to
migrate those systems
however this is not the end so we are
aware that cortex has many more
applications and use cases than just sap
data ingestion we are evaluating this
right now we also see cortex as an
enabler for decentralization because
that group of Chicago we share the
vision that data is for everyone we
don't want the data team to become a
bottleneck so we want to empower other
teams outside of the data team to ingest
data on their own without any dependency
from our own data team
so for example developers or data
analysts they should be able to get data
into gcp without requiring any help from
the data team and we created a an
internal tool which makes this happen so
we call it our internal ingestive
framework it's called Arc ninja it's
basically a user-friendly interface with
uh ready with connectors which are
already built in and the sap connector
is using cortex in the background so
what's the benefit here the the users
who who use that tool they don't need to
know anything about sap about cortex how
it works they just select origin
destination frequency and like
user-friendly drop down menu press the
button and then this will ingest it will
happen without any any help from the
data team this in turn also accelerates
our journey to the data to a data mesh
something which you're looking to
and uh we we are sure that cortex also
has other applications besides that
ingestions
so this is how we use cortex at Chicago